[Music]  the european green  deal is europe's new growth strategy  only if you destroy our natural  environment and that is no longer we  want the digital transformation to power  our economy and we want to find  european solutions in the digital age  virus  and in the space of just a few hours we  have collectively  pledged 7.4  billion euros for vaccines diagnostics  and treatments this is  europe's moment this is why the  commission is today proposing a new  recovery instrument  called next generation eu worth  750 billion euros  la commission european travail the  predator are  obtained  we are setting up one of the most  comprehensive  covet 19 vaccine portfolios in the world  this provides europeans access to the  most  promising future vaccines under  development so far